let's talk about PlayStation experience
sure I was just on over the weekend we
were all there the playing whatever
games we could playing triple-a games
playing indie games and let's go down to
catch Alexa first of all what were some
of the games that sort of stood out to
you at PSX uh res okay I'm impress on
the VR I don't I get motion sick so I
don't play your games I played it with
the Morpheus and I didn't get sick I'm
really really happy so he's like I know
you had a very interesting res
experience so there was a back room I
think he wore this to I tried to get in
yoga and they were like it's book test
really you want to wear the Tron's
vibrator soosh got a book ahead yeah so
mizoguchi being the crazy person that he
is built a suit with 26 different
vibrators on it and you went in and
played resin VR with the suit vibrating
in time to everything that's happening
and he was secretly taking video of me
while I was in the I couldn't see or
hear anything and it's him just dancing
up on me and it's up on my Twitter it's
hilarious it's just Mizoguchi just like
yeah you like that res you enjoy was he
doing it to everyone but you're the only
one that's got like evidence I think I'm
one of the few people that has evidence
of him doing it but I think he did it
for a couple other people yeah I liked
her with the end of this presentation he
just pulled the mask off and I got oh
look it's it's the maze and he's like
waves then it just shuts off yeah like
just I'm gone I'm gone yeah rah you just
saw that right okay I'm out enjoy what I
love about it what I love about it is it
lends itself so well like you were
saying to VR in terms of motion sickness
and because of the aesthetic of it you
know when you're in these like hyper
realistic world and you play something
like a drive club because they had
driveclub there as well that really sets
off your inner ear and your sense of
balance and your sense of oh this isn't
real yeah you know what I mean with
something like res or super hyper cube
because of the aesthetic of it and the
feeling of openness and also I think
because its third person and VR yeah I
think that's it it makes you a little
less sick yeah but it's the one step
removed in a way yes well we'll get into
the viewer stuff in a little while as
some of the other sort of big name games
that we saw a game that I didn't play
for a while but I got a demonstration of
and so did you as well
media molecules dream really what do you
think of it it's really interesting I
mean it's the next logical progression
of what they were already trying to do
with little big planet the big planet to
focusing very much on creation creation
tools and powering players to sort of
make their own experiences although in
talking to the developers they told me
that there will be sort of a campaign of
sorts a lot of you know created content
that exists with you know sort of
beginning and the same way there was a
little big planet but it's kind of there
to teach you how to use the tools rather
it definitely seems that way yeah and
that part was not on display they were
mainly showing off the creation tools
but they you know we're explaining that
you know this will exist but there was
really adamant that everything in the
the sort of campaign portion of the game
will be created with the same tools that
they're given to players it's not like
they're doing something on there and
with you know their coding and specific
stuff there they're using the exact same
tools they're giving everyone else to
create their own campaign so in theory
you could create something just as
robust or detailed or rich or even story
driven as what they intend to create its
it players it's funny because that's
like that's such a fascinating thing and
every time they demo it they've been
doing like these regular dev streams
every time they demo it they create
something completely different with it
and I think it's sort of helping their
cause and hurting their cause in a way
because it's hard to pin down and
explain to somebody within 30 seconds
what dreams is and why you need it and
why you want it i think it's it's very
fascinating to people who are artists or
creators like they immediately are like
oh i just want to touch this thing and
use this thing but like when you're
explain to somebody who wants to play a
game like what do I do with dreams yeah
how do I use it what am i doing with
this thing they're like whatever you
want it's like I don't it's almost like
they need a tool I'm not a game it kind
of feels like that they've been an
application development for the past
couple years because they they've made
this tool soon and I was really taken
aback by how enjoyable the process of
making actually seemed to be like yeah
it's like looking at Bob look at many
people watching bob ross on twitter
painting I could watch somebody use this
who's like good at using it yeah that's
in comparison actually to them when i
was talking to them and they were
explaining how they wanted to make it
accessible and wanted everyone to feel
like they were creating something
worthwhile and i feel like they were
failing to create and in talking about
that it did make me think of bob ross
and sort of his approach to painting and
and they said yeah
absolutely they agreed that that was a
good analogy for what they're sort of
trying to do and then they also we're
fully open about yeah this is really
about creation I mean it's not a
traditional game like we're used to
seeing it's not like oh I can pick this
up and you know play six hours and I've
done it's it is more of a creation
system and one thing that stopped us
really fascinating that they pointed out
is you're going to be able to save
whatever you create as a 3d image file
and then print it on a 3d printer yeah
or you can make characters in the game
this thing is too crazy 3d print as long
as you've accessed so you can be you
want to put them into dreams that's just
like a toy creation system and like I
just want to create a thing I could put
on my desk that's great it's not a game
it's a toy creation tool fine that's
that's how you wanted a you stand out
because like 3d modeling is essentially
standardized you can also like import
this stuff into Maya if you want it yeah
like it's all alike yes they were saying
that it is sharing and letting people
like if you just want to be a character
creator you can do that and then other
people can take what you create put it
in their own games or printed for
themselves and so it really is about
empowering players to create and not so
much acting as a traditional video game
so if you want to think of it as a
creation tool system and I think that's
a perfectly valid perspective on what
dreams actually is although again yeah
that is not super easy to communicate
gatley or easily or sexy it's weird i
was i was super cold on was until I saw
them doing that stuff and it didn't say
anything we can do is super cool like
the level of customer customization and
just things you can do it's it's
incredible the detail that you can put
into things it looks like they really
took that sort of the search mech like I
remember when you were able to search in
Little Big Planet 3 for like everything
then the search system was so good and
they really applied that to dreams in an
interesting way when they were doing the
on-stage dem weather like I'm making a
monster but I don't like drawing eyes
i'm bad at eyes so i'm gonna look up
eyes I don't see all the odds and here's
a guy who makes nothing but eyes and
here's a guy who lists himself as a guy
who makes nothing but monster puns and
so you can like mix and match from all
these people who already do amazing
things it's interesting because it's
going to be it's going to live and die
based on this community and what it
winds up being whether it winds up being
a game or a creation tool or whatever is
going to be totally dependent on what
the highest number of people is doing
with it right which is I think is
so interesting yeah because you see
merrymaker go one way where it's like
all the first couple of weeks it's all
these automatic levels animals in this
other direction yeah it's gonna be super
interesting after mario maker though and
arguably work for Minecraft as well and
in littlebigplanet I'm and I think that
there are 30 space or something exists
to succeed although you're very right
that it is very dependent on what's
community does with it and that will
dictate how the experience of all
stepping away from that we got a bunch
of games to cover uncharted 4 as well
among these we saw you now it's a
telltale love tree with yeah I want to
know how that impacts things like I love
the idea I'm all about dialogue trees in
love telltale I loved you know like the
day sex game its mass effect all
accounts not but I want to know like if
it has a tangible impact on games like
as you know this is new to get a row k
so this dialogue choice right here is
the one that they showed off and you're
right it's kind of like wait Charlie did
you like the best yeah how's that gonna
change things yeah yeah I think they
were just kind of showing off like hey
this is in there now without showing aww
so I need to know more like house day at
the game and the way that narratives can
be like if it's Dawson's that's fine
right yeah like if it's just something
to keep you engaged a cutscene it I
don't know it's just feel strange if
it's not gonna have a broader in that
John I just I want to know more it can
be one of those things where it's subtle
you know where it's one of those deals
where it doesn't look like because uh
you know David cages stuff is kind of
like that too where you make a choice
and it doesn't feel like it's affected
anything but then if you go back and you
play again you're like oh that was
really subtle what it changed telltale
does that really well sometimes too I
like that it's nathan drake like notary
public or importer exporter or something
yeah yeah just like filling out papers
and he's just like grumbling it was a
great choice narrative choice on the the
writers partner because I mean we are so
used to saying Nathan doing like these
spectacular things and dangling off a
train you know is we're so used to
seeing with precarious positions that
putting him in the most mundane setting
a possible is just really jarring is a
family man clever that was very Oliver
in their Marxist age rule it's such a
good like rubber banding of the conflict
that has always been between Nate and
Elena too yeah where it's just kind of
like dude just like slow your roll for
five minutes and then like okay maybe he
finally does for a few years and let's
see what that's done to their marriage
and then he's late for dinner because
he's talking to his brother on it's like
family slowed him down yeah anything
that's going way but why oh she's no I
love that he was like oh wait I'm
married okay that's such a bunch of Nate
Drake line to he's like oh yeah by the
way I've got this wife she hangs out
sometimes and screams at me not to jump
into pirate ships we also got to see if
one we also got to see a bunch more of a
far cry primal as well yeah yeah you're
not come on months earlier finally
playable and we know what it is yeah
yeah was it playable there yeah yeah
yeah I had a bunch of kiosks set up I
think it's uh the gameplay videos that
people have been seeing on on gamespot
and other sites it that's the same
portion that was playable on floor but
yeah just a quick taste of light it just
drops you into the world and says okay
go kill some stuff it'll be fun and I
jumped on a woolly mammoth and writing
that around Bridget stuff and yeah means
it gives you the peace master and you
can ride something and if you won't let
you ride it you can kill it and if you
and if somewhere in between somewhere in
between right there for you yeah that's
so when I was talking to Jas about it
you know he's that he's the narrative
designer of it I love that they're kind
of like stripping away more and more of
the things that I feel like sort of got
in my way and far crying getting to the
things that I really loved so like far
cry 3 you think about like all I want
that bear to eat those dudes but in
order for that bear to eat those dudes
I've got to like unlock the thing and
like throw some whatever and like yeah
and really make it happen in this one
it's just kind of like yo bear all I
want to see is a bear kill a bunch of
dudes can we make this happen yeah could
be friends with the honey badger now
that author like 17 different animals I
like that you do kind of like a blue and
a giant prehistoric death owl comes back
it's really insanely large yeah it's
like did you use it to like kill anybody
you can utterly walk it will destroy
people it's a brutal admissions and you
can upgrade it to throw like poison
bombs to keep bomber al because y is
really they're really making it just
everything I want out of a far cry he
was showing me a part where they go to
where he's hunting you know he's hunting
an animal and as he's about to shoot it
just like an eagle randomly comes down
and takes the animal he's like I guess I
don't get that animal I'm like
just happened he's like Eagle a tit man
I'm like hi is life in the freezer he's
like this is the way it is I'm just this
is gonna be so good did it feel like a
sort of a Blood Dragon II sized game or
does it like it's hard to tell and those
touch them yeah I think they're looking
to make it as big as you know as big as
for was the biggest 3 was and you know
other things that they streamline to he
said no radio towers nothing like that
you walk you what's gonna happen people
gonna be like [ __ ] this time mr.
radio I'm just walking around it's got
elements I'm just walking around
unlocking the map as I go this is stupid
where the radio towers now no one's ever
gonna say that Daddy well no I with
really big radio tower fan anything else
is just as any indie games any big stuff
oh sure like fire wash still looks at me
oh yeah funny for watch stop got radio
tower that doesn't radio tower your
non-dominant captors very prominent ears
it does game looks good I like that it's
sort of realistic but not like the the
animation sounds very cartoony like they
thought you're playing as is like really
needy hands meaty cartoon hands Alex
yeah it's beautiful and it just gets
more and more beautiful every time I see
it and which is great because it has
that same basic cartoony style but every
time I go back it's just like a little
more layered a little more beautiful we
still have very little idea what it
actually is that's fine whatever I guess
we'll know soon it seems like kind of
like a couple of steps up from what
we've seen of the you know to be
reductive that walking simulator genre
miss ago this one feels like if you
little bit more agency but it's not it
doesn't feel like a big open world to do
lots of yeah zanuck like somewhere in
the middle I kind of feels like yeah you
have a lot of like there's an incense I
know the one that we've seen over and
over and over is the one with the boom
box where yet either throw the boom box
in the lake or like take it and like
yell at them or whatnot but I was
talking to Sean vanaman when I went to
play and it sounds like um it sounds
like there will be a lot of choices like
that and what you do will sort of
influence like how like the area okay or
maybe like how like people react you or
how like Delilah talks to you like she
yeah yeah yeah yeah and by the way of
showing danamon sounds familiar but
people are totally sure we're watching
dad's the guy who wrote season one of
the walking dead for telltale so that's
you know gives me a lot of a min what
this prob
yeah they got they got Nels Anderson on
game design he was a guy at clay who
made mark of the ninja so yeah they got
it's a team that knows their stuff yeah
I'm doing yeah let's talk about the
showstopper of the press conference
Paragon yeah Eragon I dare a guy oh no
it's like it ended the show it was sort
of them felt like a whimper it was like
oh that's it it's going to move on okay
I don't know fair enough it's you can go
play it now I think using your grill
Engine launcher or yeah yeah there's
like an alpha there's alpha access right
now I don't know if that's like limited
access or everybody's open I don't know
how that's working it's very interesting
to me it's very interesting to me it's
sort of the same way like what is it
dungeon defenders like Dungeon Defenders
is basically tower defense yes but
because they are switching up the
perspective into more of a first-person
action perspective i enjoy dungeon
defenders more than I enjoy a tower
defense game and I think that's what
they're looking to try to do with MOBAs
because I think MOBAs are sort of
shrouded in this layer of sort of jargon
and you know people who are really into
them it's a very like insular community
but I think when you watch a mobo you're
kind of like I get the basic idea of
what's going on like I understand the
lands I understand that we're both
trying to get to like this other side I
get it but there are all these things
that kind of complicate and remove I
think most people from MOBAs everything
from you know that community that I was
talking about to the perspective like
the top down click only perspective
feels like one of like a strategy game
yeah exactly so I think they're trying
to do like no this is a really fun type
of game this is an amazing game four
teams of people for four groups of
friends so let's see if we can make that
accessible and fun and awesome looking
I'm kind of willing to give it a shot
after playing over watched and enjoying
it so much yeah that's the game that
really broke me out of oh this is
straight-up a first-person MOBA and it's
probably the best first-person game i
played this year me like I adore
overwatch yeah hopefully I were cracking
that not and you know the MOBA which is
quite reductive it may be expanding into
other things and ruining a bit long on
this any other shed its the games you
guys play that you want to make sure you
mentioned shoutouts to video games
either Finch enjoy them video game he's
all oh yeah actually very cool
relocations yep bound looked amazing
yeah battleborn continues to like
actually seem like a pretty cool game
even though no it seems all that
interested in it or uh a little game
called Klaus that was really good
headliners really good matt Lanter is
amazing and there's a bunch of your
stuff which we're gonna talk about yeah
second actually so oh how do cool stuff
I wish we could just lie low fat tenant
you know today names but if you want
more PSX go to gamespot com we got all
that stuff right there was right in a
second to talk about virtuality games
ever let us know what you think are some
of the games that you as a viewer in the
internet were found and entertaining and
inspiring at PlayStation experience this
year